Love is often described as heartwarming,
heart-wrenching and even heartbreaking.
So, what does the brain have
to do with it?
Everything!
The journey from first spark to last tear
is guided by a symphony
of neurochemicals and brain systems.
As you begin to fall for someone,
you may find yourself excessively
daydreaming about them
and wanting to spend more and more
time together.
This first stage of love is what
psychologists call infatuation,
or passionate love.
Your new relationship
can feel almost intoxicating,
and when it comes to the brain,
that’s not far from the truth.
Infatuated individuals show increased
activation in the ventral tegmental area.
The VTA is the reward-processing
and motivation hub of the brain,
firing when you do things like
eat a sweet treat, quench your thirst,
or in more extreme cases,
take drugs of abuse.
Activation releases the “feel good”
neurotransmitter dopamine,
teaching your brain to repeat behaviors
in anticipation
of receiving the same initial reward.
This increased VTA activity is the
reason love's not only euphoric,
but also draws you towards
your new partner.
At this first stage, it may be hard to see
any faults in your new perfect partner.
This haze is thanks
to love’s influence
on higher cortical brain regions.
Some newly infatuated individuals
show decreased activity
in the brain’s cognitive center,
the prefrontal cortex.
As activation of this region allows us
to engage in critical thought
and pass judgment,
it’s not surprising we tend to see
new relationships
through rose-colored glasses.
While this first stage of love can be
an intense rollercoaster of emotions
and brain activity,
it typically only lasts a few months,
making way for the more long-lasting
stage of love,
known as attachment,
or compassionate love.
As your relationship develops,
you may feel more relaxed
and committed to your partner
thanks in large part to two hormones:
oxytocin and vasopressin.
Known as pair-bonding hormones,
they signal trust,
feelings of social support and attachment.
In this way, romantic love
is not unlike other forms of love,
as these hormones also help bond
families and friendships.
Further, oxytocin can inhibit
the release of stress hormones,
which is why spending time
with a loved one can feel so relaxing.
As early love's suspension
of judgment fades,
it can be replaced by a more honest
understanding and deeper connection.
Alternatively, as your rose-colored
glasses begin to lose their tint,
problems in your relationship
may become more evident.
No matter the reason
a relationship ends,
we can blame the pain that accompanies
heartbreak on the brain.
The distress of a breakup activates
the insular cortex,
a region that processes pain—
both physical,
like spraining your ankle,
as well as social,
like the feelings of rejection.
As days pass, you may find yourself
once again daydreaming about
or craving contact with your lost partner.
The drive to reach out may
feel overwhelming,
like an extreme hunger or thirst.
When looking at photos
of a former partner,
heartbroken individuals again show
increased activity in the VTA,
the motivation and reward center
that drove feelings of longing
during the initial stages
of the relationship.
This emotional whirlwind also likely
activates your body’s alarm system,
the stress axis, leaving you feeling
shaken and restless.
As time goes on,
higher cortical regions which oversee
reasoning and impulse control,
can pump the brakes on this distress
and craving signaling.
Given that these regions
are still maturing
and making connections
through adolescence,
it's no wonder that first heartbreak
can feel particularly agonizing.
Activities like exercise,
spending time with friends,
or even listening to your favorite song
can tame this heartbreak stress response,
while also triggering the release
of feel good neurotransmitter dopamine.
And given time and the support,
most can heal and learn from even
the most devastating heartbreak.